die energieversorgung das thema auch für
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck er ist
jetzt gerade auf seiner reise nach
israel
israel hat zwar gas kann deutschland
aber nicht ohne weiteres kurzfristig
aushelfen doch man arbeitet gemeinsam an
lösungen sagt der wirtschaftsminister
ich habe deutlich gemacht dass
deutschland und europa jetzt erdgas
brauchen und ich denke dass israel
darüber nachdenkt wie gas route zu
nutzen die es jetzt hat und das gas nach
ägypten zu bringen und es darüber nach
europa zu transportieren was natürlich
ein schönes symbol für die
zusammenarbeit zwischen israel und
ägypten im energiebereich und für die
zukunft wäre vielleicht mit erneuerbaren
energien
sprechen wir mit csu generalsekretär
martin huber jetzt bei uns schön dass
sie da sind der ausstieg aus der
kernenergie ging er zu früh und hat man
überhaupt auch jetzt auch die
möglichkeiten da zumindest schrittweise
wie es beispielsweise auch also da
vorgeschlagen hatte zumindest als
übergangslösung zurückzufinden
die möglichkeit die kernenergie
weiterhin zu nutzen ist gegeben es gibt
ja auch ein gutachten des tüv süd der ja
auch noch mal deutlich macht dass die
drei kernkraftwerke die noch am netz
sind auch weiter betrieben werden können
die sicherheitsüberprüfungen könnten
durchgeführt werden auch die
brennelemente könnten beschafft werden
und ich finde es deswegen schon geradezu
grotesk dass ausgerechnet die grünen
dass fossile zeitalter verlängern er
übersehen sie eventuell eine chance dass
die kernenergie und der ganze ausgeht
eventuell nochmal überdacht wird
ich halte das für notwendig angesichts
dieser stunde der not in der wir uns
befinden
wir dürfen nicht vergessen es gibt in
deutschland sehr viele menschen mit die
haben abstiegsängste die wissenstand
heute nicht mehr wie sie die kosten
decken sollen in der energie für ihre
heizungen für ihre wohnungen da sind
wirklich ganz elementare abstiegsängste
vorhanden hier muss die politik und
unser vorschlag liegt auf dem tisch die
atomkraftwerke die noch am netz sind
länger laufen zu lassen lassen sie das
sagen wir ganz konkret auf den
geldbeutel der verbraucher schauen was
würde einen aufschub für die bedeuten
müssen wir dann wirklich sehr konkret
auch weniger bezahlen
naja die steigerung der energiekosten
hängt ja auch mit einer verknappung der
energie zusammen und deswegen wäre
natürlich ein länger laufen der
atomkraftwerke auch ein beitrag dazu
diese energie lücke zu schließen was ich
dann in der folge auch preisdämpfend
auswirken sollte der der facette
ausstieg aus der kernenergie nach
fukushima ist das aus ihrer sicht aus
ihrer heutigen sicht ein fehler gewesen
es
war damals ein gesamtgesellschaftlicher
konsens in dem der atomausstieg
beschlossen wurde und es geht ja auch
nicht darum am grundsatz daran zu
rütteln es gibt jetzt darum in der
stunde der not least bereits
angesprochen habe eine lösung zu finden
um die energiekosten bezahlbar zu halten
und deswegen müssen wir natürlich jetzt
auch völlig ohne ideologie und um diese
lösungen kümmern die grünen wollen
lieber kohlekraftwerke länger laufen
lassen was wie gesagt aus
klimaschutzgründen ja geradezu grotesk
ist sagt martin buber vielen herzlichen
dank ihnen für dieses gespräch
und
wir sprechen weiter über das thema bei
uns jetzt zu gast im studio ist bild
chef johannes bauer johannes schön dass
sie hier bei uns bis man fragt sich fast
gerät jetzt dieses ambitionierte projekt
völlig aus dem ruder wurden falsche
entscheidungen getroffen und welche
entscheidungen muss jetzt ganz konkret
getroffen wir werden jetzt wo so viele
menschen in ihren geldbeutel blicken und
sich fragen wie soll ich das noch
bezahlen hallo patricia hallo kira schön
dass ich heute bei euch sein kann ja ich
glaube das projekt energiewende gerät
völlig aus dem ruder noch nie waren die
energiepreise für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land so hoch so teuer
das kann's ja in deutschland gar nicht
sein dass die leute ihre energie nicht
mehr bezahlen können ja wir hören dass
von unseren leserinnen und lesern immer
wieder dass sie ihre elektrogeräte nicht
mehr benutzen können längst gehen kleine
firmen pleite die sich die energiepreise
nicht mehr leisten können das ist eine
katastrophe und es ist dazu gekommen
weil angela merkel eine
kurzschlussreaktion hatte nach der
katastrophe von fukushima und ganz
schnell den atomausstieg durchgepeitscht
hat nun ist es so dass ich auch kein fan
des atoms bin des atomstroms bin
natürlich müssen wir früh oder später
auch mehr und mehr zur regenerativen
energiequellen kommen aber bis das eben
einwandfrei funktioniert brauchen wir
unbedingt die atomkraft und deswegen
halte ich es für vollkommen falsch das
letztes jahr am letzten tag des jahres
drei einwandfrei laufen der atommeiler
in deutschland abgeschaltet wurden und
dass das für dieses jahr mit den
verbleibenden drei mit unseren letzten
atomkraftwerken auch geplant ist könnte
denn ein aufschub des kernenergie
ausstiegs überhaupt der derzeitigen
preis explosion entgegen wirken also
würde das jetzt überhaupt noch was
bringen
es würde insofern entspannung bringen
als wir jetzt ja drei laufende
atomkraftwerke haben wenn ich die auch
nach herausnehme aus der rechnung steigt
um ein weiteres mal die abhängigkeit von
anderen ländern und es steigt natürlich
auch das verfügbare angebot das angebot
schwankt ganz stark es ist auch richtig
dass wir manchmal sogar strom abgeben
müssen weil die regenerativen dann
plötzlich so viel produzieren aber was
eine grundsätzliche sicherung des
stromangebots betrifft würde es
unbedingt helfen drei atomkraftwerke die
wir jetzt noch haben weiter laufen zu
lassen man sollte sogar drüber
diskutieren sehr umstritten in diesem
land aber man sollte sogar darüber
diskutieren ob wir nicht für die
nächsten jahrzehnte bis es wirklich gut
funktioniert mit den regenerativen eine
rückkehr planen und vielleicht sogar
noch mal ein atomkraftwerk bauen wir es
zum beispiel die franzosen tun wirst die
finnen tun hier im internationalen
vergleich sind wir da stehen wir absolut
auf einem alleine platz muss man sagen
die finnen frankreich du sprichst es an
polen die bauen meiler während bei uns
die grünen davon sprechen die kohle
weiter zu fördern wo liegt das
missverständnis hier in deutschland
atomkraft der gehen bei vielen erst mal
die alarmglocken los aber es könnte uns
derzeit jetzt in dieser krise so sehr
helfen ja und wir haben ja nicht nur die
jetzige krise mit der ukraine krise und
der großen abhängigkeit von
energieanbietern im ausland darunter
darunter ja auch die diktatur russland
sondern wir haben ja auch noch das thema
umwelt krise klimawandel und hier ist es
doch ganz klar dass die emission von
braun- und steinkohle einen erheblichen
den erheblichen teil dazu beitragen ich
finde es grotesk dass die grünen die
zeitenwende von der gerade so viel die
rede ist nicht begreifen als jetzt
müssen wir uns auch verändern was unsere
energiepolitik betrifft sondern dass
ausgerechnet die grünen denen doch die
umwelt angeblich so sehr am herzen liegt
weiter diese emission in die luft blasen
wollen mit der braunkohle mit der
steinkohle sogar erhöhen wollen und
dahinter liegt natürlich etwas
vertriebsjahr du sprichst das ja an
dass man gar nicht anders beschreiben
kann als mit einer deutsche nur angst
vor der atomkraft das ist eben sehr
geprägt worden nach tschernobyl wo ihr
auch in tschernobyl ein alter
sowjetischer reaktor mit massiven
bedienungsfehlern in die katastrophe
getrieben wurde diese katastrophe flößt
uns bis heute angst sein und nicht
verstehe dass ich erinnere mich selbst
und ich war ein kind damals ich erinnere
mich selbst noch an diese zeit aber
tschernobyl ist nicht vergleichbar mit
modernen atomkraftwerken jetzt gebaut
werden natürlich ist es eine
risikobehaftete technologie aber wenn
man anschaut wie viele menschen sterben
statistisch gesehen durch den unter
anderem den ausstoß von schadstoffen
durch braun und steinkohle und wie viele
menschen sterben statistisch gesehen
durch die nukleartechnologie
dann ist der faktor zu ungunsten der
kohle mehrere 100 fach höher ja und das
ist etwas das ganz viele in deutschland
nicht auf dem schirm haben weil hier
viele eben auch mit dieser atom-angst
aufgewachsen sind gut tun pausewang der
eine oder andere wird diese autorin
kennen hat eine komplette generation an
kindern in den 80ern und 90ern geimpft
mit büchern wie die wolke vor der
strahlung der ominösen strahlung und
dazu gehört natürlich auch dass die
grünen immer wieder sagen sie erinnern
an die atomkatastrophe von fukushima nun
ist fukushima eine katastrophe gewesen
ja auch ganz schlimm ist aber das waren
die überschwemmung das war ein tsunami
der tsunami hat dann auch ein
atomkraftwerk betroffen das ist eine
katastrophe gar keine frage aber zu
insinuieren dass dort ein modernes
einigermaßen modernes japanisches
atomkraftwerk ohne eine große
umweltkatastrophe beschädigt worden sei
aus sich selbst heraus ist natürlich
grundfalsch es gab keine primäre
atomkatastrophe fukushima die leute sind
dort ertrunken und durch diese
erzählungen ist es einfach ist in
deutschland eine dauerhafte angst
entstanden und ich glaube wir müssen
trotzdem aber noch mal sehr
ergebnisoffen darüber diskutieren mehr
noch ich glaube deutschland muss
unbedingt an der atomkraft festhalten
und damit wirst du nicht der einzige
viele experten viele politiker fordern
jetzt dass eine diskussion die wir hier
natürlich auch weiter verfolgen werden
johannes bitter hierbei gilt vielen
herzlichen dank für deinen besuch im
studio ich danke euch